-Good evening.
I'm Seth Meyers.
This is "Late Night."
We hope you're
doing well tonight.
And now, if you don't mind,
we're going to get to the news.
President Biden
announced yesterday
that his administration
will lower the cost of insulin
for everyone, regardless
of their Medicare status.
And not a moment too soon.
[ Laughter ]
We didn't make that.
That's an actual product.
During the same event
at the White House yesterday,
President Biden
pulled out a copy
of Florida senator Rick Scott's
12-point plan to rescue America
and said that it could end
Social Security and Medicare.
Oh, that'll be popular
in Florida.
[ Laughter ]
What's his next idea?
Abolishing visits
from grandkids?
According to a new book,
former president Trump
would tell White House visitors
that he had a secret bathroom.
And visitors would tell him,
"Sir, that's just a closet."
[ Laughter ]
[ As Trump ]
That's part of the secret.
[ Laughter ]
[ Normal voice ] The book
also claims that while meeting
then-president Barack Obama
in 2016 after being elected,
former president Trump
asked Obama
how he kept his approval ratings
so high.
"What'd he say," asked Biden.
[ Laughter ]
Senate Minority Leader
Mitch McConnell said yesterday
that he will support
the bipartisan bill
to reform the
Electoral Count Act of 1887.
I guess he still feels bad
after voting no the first time.
[ Laughter ]
Britain's Prince George
reportedly told his classmates,
"My dad will be king,
so you better watch out."
[ Laughter ]
Which, you have to admit,
is a crushing comeback
for a 9-year-old.
"Tag, you're it."
"If by it you mean
the once and future king!"
New York mayor Eric Adams
announced yesterday
that he will launch
a chess council
to develop more
plant-based recipes
for public school lunches.
Meanwhile, most of
the high school students
will continue to enjoy
plant-based recess.
[ Laughter ]
And finally, after receiving
criticism from viewers,
Netflix removed the LGBTQ tag
from its new series
about serial killer
Jeffrey Dahmer.
On the downside, they left
the food and travel tag.
[ Laughter ]
And that was the monologue.
I don't know why --
You know, but...
You don't pick
the ones you end on.